what are your thoughts on those
conspiracy videos saying that you're
illiterate did you hear about this no
what you don't know about this how long
did I have four years later and Leah
Michelle's officially putting to bed the
rumor she can't read it's just wild in
an interview with the New York Times the
actress addresses the conspiracy that
began in 2018 which involved her time on
Glee Fain is the most important thing in
our culture now and if there's one thing
I learned it's that no one's just gonna
hand it to you
I love him Leah tells the times quote I
went to Glee every single day I knew my
lines every single day and then there's
a rumor online that I can't read or
write it's sad it really is yeah the
rumor is that the show's producer Ryan
Murphy read Leah her lines a theory
she's actually shut down in the past and
by the way not only do I have to
memorize pages and Pages they said that
Ryan Murphy would have to read the lines
to me yes Ryan called me he's like do do
people think that I have the time in my
life to come and do this I got accepted
to NYU like I I mean it's it's the most
bizarre thing that's ever happened and
Leah thinks there's a gender bias at
play with this whole thing telling the
times quote I think often if I were a
man a lot of this wouldn't be the case
on top of that the singers responding to
another Glee allegation that she created
a toxic work environment on set I just
want you to know that I've taken some
time to get to know you and that who you
are is important to me so that I don't
feel like I'm being used when you ask me
to join the Glee Club pretty much now
Leah doesn't get into this specific
allegations but does offer insight into
why her co-stars might have been rubbed
the wrong way quote I have an edge to me
I work really hard I leave no room for
mistakes that level of perfectionism or
that pressure of perfectionism left me
with a lot of blind spots the thing is
is that no one will ever know what that
experience was like except for the
people that were in the choir room
together and now you can say Leah's
having a full circle moment because
after playing Fanny Bryce years ago on
Glee
I'll flicker than flare up
Leah's taking on the role on Broadway
and she says she's learning from
mistakes she made in the past admitting
that after an intense time of reflection
she realizes the impact of being
professional on and off camera quote it
means not only going and doing a good
job when the camera is rolling but also
when it's not and that wasn't always the
most important thing for me
foreign
[Music]